was macht eigentlich ein elefant in der
milchstraße und funktionierten
kugelschreiber tatsächlich im weltall
nicht oder ist das alles nur propaganda
hier kommt unglaubliche welt auch
packten die schon vor leica im all war
dass leute ganz kurz bevor es losgeht
wir haben ja unser eigenes doktor watson
merge gelauntes gibt t shirts es gibt
rudis und zwar mit einem von der nasa
offiziell abrufen design des nasa mars
rover person wir uns das ganze gibt's
jetzt auch in einer v2 wir haben noch
mal das ganze ein bisschen verbessert es
gibt jetzt auch doktor watson tags und
wenn dieses video online geht habt ihr
noch zwei tage zeit dieses match zu
bestellen
also geht jetzt auf www.ndr.de und
sichert euch eure t shirts oder hoodies
und jetzt geht es los und zwar mit 1 der
schwerelose triegel schreiber
kennt ihr das auch er kommt gerade vom
weltraumspaziergang auf der
internationalen raumstation zurück und
wollte mal eben die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie schriftlich
nachprüfen oder möglichst viele
nachkommastellen von pi aufschreiben und
plötzlich mist ich habe meinen stift von
der erde mit dabei so wird das mit den
notizen natürlich nichts stifter die mit
tinte schreiben brauchen schwerkraft
damit die tinte aus dem stift auf das
papier kommt und wie wir alle wissen ist
dass mit der schwerkraft im weltall so
eine sache
deswegen hat die nasa in den 60er jahren
mehrere millionen us dollar investiert
um einen stift zu erfinden der auch in
der schwerelosigkeit tinte auf das
papier bringt die russischen space race
gegner schickten ihre astronauten
hingegen nur mit primitiven stiften ins
all
so oder so ähnlich wird es zumindest der
mythos vom super teuren space penh
aber bevor wir darüber sprechen was an
dieser geschichte mythos und was
realität ist fragt ihr euch bestimmt
warum tut es nicht einfach der gute alte
bleistift nun ja die miene von einem
bleistift bericht schicht für schicht ab
damit schreibt ein bleistift auf papier
aber nicht alles davon landet auf dem
papier in der schwerelosigkeit liegen
die einzelnen graphit plätzchen durch
die luft könnten von leuten eingeatmet
werden oder sogar zu einem kurzschluss
führen denn grafite leitet ja
elektrizität und das holz von einem
bleistift ist natürlich brennbar ein
no-go auf einer raumstation
okay was ist jetzt also dran an der
geschichte vom space penn in erster
linie ist die geschichte leider ein
mythos
die nasa hat zwar ein paar sehr teure
mechanische bleistifte gekauft und als
das herauskam gab es wohl noch ein
bisschen ärger wegen des preises aber
einen eine millionen dollar teuren space
penn hat die nasa entwickelt das heißt
aber nicht dass es keinen space penn
gibt nun kommt der nicht aus dem taschen
der amerikanischen steuerzahler sondern
von der firma fischer
die haben nämlich tatsächlich circa eine
million euro in die entwicklung von
einem ganz besonderen stift gesteckt und
1966 kam er dann raus der fischer ag 7
und das ag steht hier für anti gravity
hier wird tinte verwendet die unter
druck steht so dass sie auch gegen die
schwerkraft fließt in der reagiert wenn
der realo gi das ist die fleece
wissenschaft zum beispiel von fließenden
flüssigkeiten spricht man auch von pixo
tropez fun fact dieser stift
funktioniert auch unter wasser
bei extremer kälte und bei extremer
hitze würde die farbe vom stift grünen
statt blau und dass die amerikaner den
russen vorausfahren ist auch so ein
mythos beide länder haben diesen stift
gekauft und mit ins weltall gebracht und
noch heute kann man diesen stoff kaufen
für ungefähr 50 dollar
jetzt geht es aber erstmal weiter mit
fakt nummer zwei wir euch das
hubble-weltraumteleskop datenvolumen
cloud wenn ihr uns auf instagram folgt
und das solltet ihr auf jeden fall tun
dann habt ihr bestimmt schon mitbekommen
dass wir große fans von hubble
weltraumteleskops sind und auch wenn
sich unser hilfreiche super fernglas
langsam in den ruhestand verabschiedet
gibt es ein bild das man unbedingt mal
gesehen haben sollte die größe des
universums ist für uns männer
nämlich manchmal echt schwer zu
verstehen aber dieses eine bild von
hubble kann uns dabei helfen zumindest
im ansatz zu erahnen wie groß das
universum wirklich ist was ihr hier seht
ist die andromeda-galaxie zwei millionen
lichtjahre entfernt so weit so gut
die unfassbare größe dieser galaxie aber
auch von diesem bild wird aber erst
deutlich wenn man anfängt rhein zu
zoomen in herz image aus einem nebel
werden dann langsam kleine punkte gehen
wir weiter rein werden es immer mehr und
das krasse ist jeder einzelne dieser
winzig kleinen punkte die man bevor wir
ein gesucht haben nicht mal erkennen
konnte ist ein stern und wenn wir so nah
wie möglich heranzoomen dann sieht es
sogar so aus als wären all diese sterne
nebeneinander und hier liegen immer noch
super viele lichtjahre dazwischen
die sterne sind einfach so weit von uns
weg das 10 lichtjahre mal eben wie ein
katzensprung wirken wenn euch das selber
anschauen wollt dann solltet ihr
übrigens in einen wlan hotspot gehen
denn dieses bild ist achtung vier
gigabyte groß ein einzelnes bild das ist
eine der wenigen aufnahmen die einen
wirklich mal fühlen lassen wie unfassbar
riesig unser universum eigentlich ist
denn wir sind gerade im goldenen
zeitalter des universums es ist genug
dass es schon leben gibt also uns zum
beispiel und es ist jung genug dass wir
noch in der lage sind andere galaxien zu
sehen
denn der weltraum breitet sich immer
weiter aus und das sogar schneller als
das licht
das heißt große zivilisationen in der
weit entfernten zukunft werden
vielleicht gar keine ahnung haben dass
es andere galaxien gibt weil der welt
rum um sie herum so leer ist dass sie
gar nicht so weit gucken können wir
jetzt gerade mit hubble tun können wir
hier bei doktor watson lesen ja eine
menge studien und texte und da fällt es
mir abends manchmal echt schwer mich
noch zu motivieren und mehr über andere
themen zu lesen die mich eigentlich
total interessieren aber mit blink ist
habe ich da jetzt einen sehr guten weg
gefunden so viel wie möglich in super
kurzer zeit zu lernen denn blinkt ist
nimmt ganze bücher und macht aus ihnen
15 minütige text und audio erklärer
sogenannte links und hier gibt es alles
von philosophie und psychologie bis hin
zur physik und ernährung und es gibt die
total viele bücher die mir schon alle
mal empfohlen wurden für dich aber
bisher einfach nicht die zeit hatte
statt also eine viertelstunde auf
instagram oder so rum zu scrollen kann
ich einfach mal eben die wesentlichen
punkte aus eine kurze geschichte der
mensch
weit von yuval nur harry oder kurze
antworten auf große fragen von stephen
hawking erfahren und mittlerweile gibt
es auch hörbücher in voller länge wenn
ich dann doch mal ganz tief in ein thema
einsteigen will
im moment gibt es eine aktion extra für
euch auf linke.de / doktor watson
erhaltet ihr 25 prozent rabatt auf ein
jahres abo blinkt des premium und damit
kauft ja auch nicht die katze im sack
das abo könnt ihr vorhaben sieben tage
lang kostenlos testen und euch erst dann
entscheiden ob das was für euch ist oder
nicht
falls euch das jetzt interessiert dann
klickt einfach unten auf den ersten link
in der video beschreibung und fangt an
zu lernen nummer drei das weltall ist
eigentlich gar nicht so weit weg
die unendlichen weiten die uns das
hubble-weltraumteleskop zeigt sind
millionen lichtjahre entfernt und wir
als menschheit haben tausende jahre auf
diesem planeten hier verbracht ist wie
die erde das erste mal verlassen konnten
und ich glaube deswegen fühlt sich das
weltall für uns immer noch so fern an
aber in wahrheit ist es das eigentlich
gar nicht denn von der oberfläche der
erde sind es gerade mal 100 kilometer
bis sich im weltall bin wenn ich mit dem
auto vertikalen nach oben fahren könnte
wäre ich in unter einer stunde dort
vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen
weniger wenn dort keine blitzer sind und
seitdem spacex einen tesla ins weltall
geschickt hat sind meine chancen da sich
dort oben im weltall einen autounfall
bauer auch nicht mehr 0
aber spaß beiseite auch wenn ab 100
kilometern offiziell das weltall beginnt
ist dort oben natürlich erstmal noch
nicht ganz so viel los die
internationale raumstation fliegt zum
beispiel um einiges höher
aber wenn ich das mit distanzen hier auf
der erde vergleiche ist auch das gar
nicht so weit weg
ich bin gerade wie man unschwer erkennen
kann in köln
und wenn jetzt gerade die iss über
meinen kopf fliegen würde dann wäre
hamburg weiter weg als die astronauten
und astronauten auf der raumstation
denn die iss fliegt ungefähr 400
kilometer über der erde und das ist
ziemlich genau so weit wie von hamburg
nach köln von frankfurt nach münchen
oder wie der schulweg meines opas und
zwar bergauf in beide richtungen
aber wir wissen ja alle was die beste
maßeinheit ist deswegen hier kommt es
3800 fußballfelder ist die iss von der
erde entfernt oder eine millionen 900
4761 döner
liebe grüße an funk und jetzt gehts
weiter nummer vier die sonne ist super
laut mit unserer sonne verbinden wir
viele eigenschaften sie ist groß sie ist
hell wie es verdammt heiß und das
alleine macht sie eigentlich schon zu
einer ziemlich lebensfeindlichen
umgebung aber das ist nicht der einzige
grund warum wir sie wahrscheinlich von
eurer urlaubs bucket list streichen
sollte denn neben der extremen hitze und
dem erhöhten hautkrebsrisiko ist die
sonne auch noch verdammt laut aber warum
eigentlich und wie hört sich das an
die sonne ist innen heiß und außen
kälter genau wie die erde
aber natürlich sprechen wir von komplett
anderen verhältnissen der kälteste teil
der sonne ist immer noch deutlich wärmer
als der heißeste punkt des erdkerns und
auch wenn das von hier unten so aussieht
hat die sonne keine feste oberfläche wie
die erde
von außen ist unser stern einen sog aus
extrem heißen plasma und dieser ständige
fluss von super heißen material an die
oberfläche und abgekühlte material
zurück zum zentrum erzeugt eine
unglaubliche lautstärke unsere sonne
macht also die ganze zeit einen
höllischen lärm aber durch das vakuum im
weltall können die schallwellen eben
nicht zu uns wandern bzw
streng genommen gibt es ja gar keine
schallwellen den schall benötigt
zwingend ein medium durch dass er sich
bewegen kann
was wäre jetzt aber wenn wir eine art
schal kanal zwischen der sonne und uns
bauen würden in dieser schalke hat auch
tatsächlich die erdatmosphäre
dann würde sich die sonne ungefähr so
anhören
mit dem kleinen unterschied dass dieses
geräusch hier auf der erde trotz der
distanz von sonne und erde immer noch
110 dezibel laut wäre und zwar den
ganzen tag das ist lauter als bei einem
konzert und ungefähr vergleichbar damit
als wir euch jemand die ganze zeit
direkt ins ohr schreien
hörverlust kann hier schon nach zwei
minuten eintreten also auch wenn das
sonst eher unpraktisch ist bin ich hier
glaube ich ziemlich froh dass im
weltraum ein vakuum herrscht nummer 5
der elefant in der milchstraße stellt
euch mal vor ich würde jetzt auffallen
dass in eurem zimmer schon immer ein
elefant war ihr habt ihn einfach nur nie
gesehen genauso haben sich
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von der nasa gefühlt als die 2010 eine
bisher nicht bekannte struktur in
unserer galaxie gefunden haben
dieses objekt erstreckt sich ungefähr
25.000 lichtjahre über und unter unserer
galaxie
natürlich handelte sich hierbei nicht
wirklich um einen riesigen elefanten
aber die größenverhältnisse sind
ungefähr so als würde ein elefant bei
euch im wohnzimmer stehen
[Musik]
in wahrheit handelte sich hierbei um
gigantische blasen die die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
firma bartels getauft haben woher diese
blasen kommen hat seitdem für große
rätsel gesorgt und erst vor kurzem ist
man diesem phänomen ein kleines bisschen
auf die schliche gekommen
es gibt hinweise dafür dass diese blasen
die im nachwirkungen eines energetischen
events sind das zwischen 9 bis 6
millionen jahre her ist damals hat ein
gigantisches schwarzes loch eine riesige
menge an gas und kosmischen staub
verschluckt und dann diese blasen quasi
ausgelöst und das ist nicht das erste
mal dass wir dachten wir wissen
eigentlich schon alles über die
milchstraße bis 1920 ist man davon
ausgegangen dass sich alle sterne im
universum in unserer galaxie befinden
dann hat edwin hubble namensgeber für
das berühmte teleskop einen stern
entdeckt von dem er die genaue distanz
messen konnte so hat er herausgefunden
dass das was wie kosmischer nebel in der
milchstraße aussieht eigentlich andere
galaxien sind so das waren auch schon
wieder fünf unglaubliche space fakten
falls ihr noch mehr sehen wollt dann
könnt ihr euch hier oben die letzte
folge anschauen da geht es um eine
riesige alkohol wolke einen
intergalaktischen surf trip und darum
wie man den urknall im fernseher sehen
kann und für die nächsten folgen von
space fakten wollen wir immer gerne
einen community fakt von euch mit
einbauen wenn ihr also bock habt im
nächsten video mit zu erscheinen dann
schreibt uns eure lieblings space fragt
unten in die kommentare
außerdem habt ihr wie gesagt nur noch
ganz kurz zeit unsere
im neuen t shirts und hoodies zu
bestellen also besucht www.mdr.de um
euch etwas vom allerersten doktor watson
match überhaupt zu sichern
vergesst auch nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren für weitere folgen aber
ansonsten vor allem bleibt neugierig
patrick
[Musik]